it's time for a Tuesday PFT ot Chris
Sims back in the saddle for the extra 15
minutes or so that we do to address
topics that we weren't able to get to
during PFT live or things that we'd like
to expand upon a little bit more I want
to start with a little business
information here this came from Daniel
Kaplan now of the athletic royalties
earned last year by players for group
merchandising Jersey sales etc Tom Brady
once again the top of the heap with an
extra two point three five million
dollars and when you're making 1516
million you're playing football that's
not chump change so two point three five
million for Brady all from these jerseys
that people keep buying Chris we talked
about that recently your kids gone
through how many Tom Brady jerseys he's
outgrown them right more and more Tom
Brady jerseys I have a feeling they're
to keep selling Tom Brady jerseys after
he finally retires if he ever does I
think you're right I mean well he's hit
that status I mean he's an American icon
I mean that he is I mean I'm not so sure
I might not buy a Tom Brady jersey at
some point I mean that's he's that he's
that special and yeah I think grown men
and kids are gonna continue to buy it
and I get it and it's cool I mean it's
unbelievable the guy's had the run that
he's had I mean really I mean the career
the accomplishments the second wind of
the career Mike you know I mean a lot of
New England people don't like me and
because I said he took the air to the
football and I said back in 2012 and
2013 he wasn't one of the five best
quarterbacks in the league and man ever
since 2014 he's just here II changed his
career too and these three changes
throwing motion and he's just become a
player that's closer to the guy we saw
at the start of his career than the guy
I saw in 2011 12 and 13 and I'm just
amazed by it and he's selfless and done
so many good things and he's just still
playing at such a high level you know
and another point that came from the
list that Kaplan published dak Prescott
yeah I was going to make 2.0 to 5
million this year made 2 million in
those royalties sales and that that is
one of the tangible benefits of being
the Cowboys
back and that's one of the pressure
points in those negotiations the Cowboys
want credit for that yeah and dak
Prescott agents are not gonna care what
team you are all they care about is
maximizing the football contract and
they're not going to give you credit for
its the Cowboys and you can sell more
jerseys and you can get the Dannon
yogurt sponsorship and you can get a
broadcasting job when your career is
over no we want the most money possible
but still for dak Prescott it just shows
he does make more money off the field
than he currently makes on sale that
should change that should change at some
point don't you think it should happen
before the start of the season I mean I
was talking to this the other day of all
the quarterbacks out there other than
Jameis Winston to Marcus Mariota that
you know they have to prove that they're
going to earn their second contract
there are two guys who are eligible for
second contracts and haven't gotten them
yet Jared Goff and dak Prescott they
both should have them and especially
Prescott he's going into the last year
of his contract and the Cowboys are
gonna run the risk of a franchise tag
dilemma if they don't get this done but
I feel like they've got a long way to go
to get something done
yeah I do too and yet he's a fourth
round pick I mean he hasn't made big
money yet in his career so he's even you
know more desperate to cash in than a
guy like Jared Goff out with the Rams
and I would think yes I mean as we've
talked about a lot if they dangled out
you know a pretty good market value deal
with some big guarantees and and all
that I just I would find it hard to
believe that dak Prescott wouldn't take
the deal at this point and in the Dallas
Cowboys I certainly would the team you
got right now and if you're feeling good
about Kellen Moore it offens a
coordinator who I'd be scared because
I'd go oh gosh well I mean we're the
type of team we might go thirteen and
three and be in the NFC playoffs and
then desk dak Prescott is gonna ask for
40 million a year yeah right so you know
do it now get him from the low maybe
same thing applies to receive a Remora
Cooper who's going into the last year of
his contract a contract for which the
Cowboys traded last year with the
Raiders not a whole lot of progress on
an Amari Cooper deal meanwhile Saints GM
Mickey Loomis indicated recently that
the team has had some conversations with
receiver Michael Thomas after the cam
Jordan deal was done last week the
indications are that Michael Thomas will
be the next one to get a contract and
this is a guy Chris who is a game
changer yeah he is intense
in in the postseason before their
divisional round game against the Eagles
he was crazed I mean I have never seen a
receiver that locked in and that focused
and that determined before a game this
guy is one of the best receivers in the
NFL and he's going to deserve a contract
that recognizes that yes he is I mean
yeah one of the best receivers in the
NFL huge vital piece to what the Saints
do on the offensive side of the ball you
know he's a the Saints they believe in
these big slot receivers basically you
know we saw you know marques colston if
I really kind of have this type of role
before Michael Thomas got there but yeah
they move Michael Thomas on the outside
and we know he can catch jump balls and
50/50 balls and go routes and all that
but his real beauty is what he does on
the inside of that field he's almost
like one of those that Letta cast
catching tight ends you know is he a
receiver is he a big body what he is
he's fearless he's physical they love
him as far as what he is as a student of
the game and his love for the game and
the work ethic so I would imagine that
he's gonna get a contract here soon
that's gonna put him in the conversation
for the highest-paid wide receiver in
the NFL eventually Jake Coomer oh maybe
in that category as well he has received
some high praise from Aaron Rodgers who
was just looking for some receivers he
can trust and Rodgers has raved about
Camaros ability to do everything that he
expects of him and and this is a
delicate balance you have to be able to
be in the right place at the right time
you have to win that trust you have to
show that you can make the catch when
the ball comes your way and I Rodgers
just went on and on about what he does
he says it's an eight that that that
that's what separates him from a guy you
might not trust as much because you know
that he's gonna do it right he's always
gonna be in the right spot he knows what
he's doing all the time and what the
other guys are doing and when he gets a
chance to make plays he makes plays and
he does it in a super classy understated
way now I don't know why that matters
but apparently it's a factor for Aaron
Rodgers and ultimately the quarterback
decides who he's gonna throw to Chris
let me put this to you yeah was there
ever a guy on the field that you either
felt like I want to throw it to him
because I like how he plays regardless
of whether he's open or
guy that would be open but you just
didn't like that you shied away from
throwing the ball too well definitely I
mean you know to go in the positive one
first right like I'll go with a guy like
I kill your I kill your was like our
slot receiver with the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers he gave me a warm and cozy
feeling one because I knew he was smart
he was gonna read the defense the right
way and if the play broke down I knew he
could try to make the proper adjustment
in like give me a you know get out of
jail for free pass where he'd find the
right hole in the zone to settle down
and I just trusted that he would see
things the same way I would and for that
yes he was always one of my go-to guys
because I felt that trust within him and
I think that's what Rogers is trying to
say you know so many of these routes
especially by slot receivers and things
in the NFL it is read the coverage read
the defense on the go Rodgers thinks
he's breaking out oh gosh he broke in
now it's an interception pick-six and
you know we're losing a game and those
few plays can change a season around in
a hurry as we all know so you got to
have that guy within your offense and I
would think with Randall Cobb not being
there right now I mean we know they're
gonna use Davante Adams in the slot a
little bit but they probably need to
find that other guy that can work the
middle of the field and I think that's
where cumaru seems to be in the
conversation to be that guy that runs
the option routes the jerk routes where
you're read coverages on the go and
Rodgers doesn't have to you know double
clutch it or double pump it to go oh I
hope he does the right thing and then
you know it you know becomes a downward
trend of bad throw misconnection
interception whatever it may be so who's
the guy that you I was just telling that
come on come on
well no but there were certain guys
where they were extremely athletic and
maybe more talented than a guy like
let's say with like I kill you're okay
but when they were certain routes I'd go
oh man I mean this guy's awesome but
there were certain routes where I'd go I
don't know I just don't trust him to
read the coverage here I'm gonna play
the other side here yeah he's awesome if
he's on the outside he's gonna run a go
route or a comeback or a slant I trust
him there but there was some talented
receivers I played with where I went oh
they went in the slot and now they're
gonna run the Ike Hilliard play from the
slot I don't know
about this unless it's like just this
absolute clean you know elementary look
to where I go okay he won't screw that
up yeah you'd be scared to do it but no
I'm not gonna give any names and getting
my ex teammates mad at me and beat me up
or anything like that
was there ever a guy that you resisted
throwing the ball to because he kept
complaining that he was open and you
weren't throwing in the ball no no I
can't say that I did I mean that's
almost every receiver ever in the
history of football
I mean it's unreal whether I was in
college the NFL receivers coming over
telling you their open mic telling you
they're open then you get a picture
right and you sit down to your coach and
you know you got your quarterback coach
next to you who's heard the receiver
tell you he's open and right and you're
looking at it and you're going wait
isn't that the play that you know Johnny
just said he was open on and the coach
looked look at the picture and he goes
yeah don't listen to him he doesn't know
what he's talking about and you know
there's four guys around them there's a
it can't tell you how many instances
that happens receivers and what they
think is open is not always open to a
quarterback or realistically open in
general all right we're gonna flip it
over to the defensive side of the ball
the Oakland Raiders will be the Hard
Knocks team this year and one of the
potential storylines the future of
safety carl joseph the raiders did not
pick up the fifth year option for the
former first-round pick from west
virginia he's been a disappointment more
often than not injuries have been a
major factor now the Raiders saying all
the right things via Paul gone through
the team's defensive coordinator that
Joseph has responded well they're happy
with where he is how much of this is the
Jon Gruden psychological warfare where
you're pushing a guy's buttons to try to
get him to live up to his potential by
not picking up the option by suggesting
that you know who knows what kind of a
future the guy has or maybe doesn't have
with the Oakland Raiders yeah well I'll
ii mean from the outside it looks like
like right now Gruden's trying to build
the guy up a little bit right that
that's you know they didn't give him
that fifth-year option yes he's he's you
know underperform for being a top 20
pick coming out of West Virginia guy I
certainly like coming outside I've been
wrong on him to this point to okay but
yeah they don't want off from the fifth
year option and I think a lot of players
when they see that in their first-round
pick you know that's the first time in
their NFL career they're going man
nobody wants me they don't want me the
team that loved me and picked me first
and now
they're kind of wavering and Gruden was
very quick to come out and go hey this
just because we didn't give him the
fifth-year option doesn't mean we don't
really you know have faith in Karl
joseph' and think he can be something
he's just gonna have to prove it to get
that type of money but I think they see
the talent there he's just a guy that's
got to put it all together and maybe now
with the guy like little Marcus Joyner
being around and now you got a you know
the Jonathan Abrams kid first-round pick
out of Mississippi State it's certainly
gonna make that defense better and maybe
be able to get him a more defined role
in the defense to where there was games
were you know when I would watch the
Raiders and go with it man there's karl
joseph playing strong safety at 185
pounds that ain't good that's not gonna
work you know so now maybe they can find
a role for him on the defense that fits
his skill set a little bit better to
make it make it all work yeah it'll be
interesting to see how it plays out I
mean look they saw a lot of talent in
him but that was a different regime
right Kenzie is gone and we've seen
first-round picks that were brought in
by Reggie McKenzie systematically
eliminated from that team from Khalil
Mack
to Amari Cooper and now who knows Karl
Joseph could be the next but it looks
like at least he's gonna have a chance
one guy who got a chance last year and
made the most of it
Ravens quarterback Lamar Jackson and
Chris we were talking about this earlier
off-air the mixed signals were getting
from the Ravens about praise for Jackson
and his development as a passer but
still some concern about what he needs
to do to improve he himself has
acknowledged recently he wasn't
mastering the play calls the way he
needed to and I think they're
simplifying that for him but but how
good do we expect him to be he kind of
exceeded expectations last year from a
running standpoint but not really from a
throwing standpoint and he could do both
very well when he was at Louisville yes
he could can he become that polished
passer right Mike that's I think what we
both want to see from the guy you know
we know he can run
we know he understands how to play the
position and all that but can he be like
surgical within the pocket like Drew
Brees is and I don't saying he has to be
like Drew Brees he's got to have moments
of that where you go okay yeah we're not
gonna be able to run today we're not
gonna build to trick them into a run
game we're gonna have to drop back and
you're gonna have to you know sit in the
pocket 30 times and make 20 good
decision
and throw 20 accurate footballs to go 24
30 and throw 4 280 yards and 2
touchdowns and no interceptions that's
what I got to see from Lamar Jackson and
we saw no semblance of that last year so
I got to see it to believe it but you're
right the offseason seemed cryptic to me
I know I said a few weeks ago I had
heard from people in Baltimore that the
offseason didn't get off to a great
start as far as OTAs practices from him
right he he didn't know they were
changing the offense around that was
certainly an odd come and you know now
we hear about okay fumbling the language
around but I also felt like we heard
like a little bit of a Ravens propaganda
at the end where the coaches were trying
to put a positive spin on Lamar Jackson
and how he well he's improved and we
still need to get better and then he
makes a comment Lamar Jackson like he
might go see Tom House so to me if you
were really kicking butt you wouldn't be
going oh I need to go see Tom House now
for the first time ever in between OTAs
and training camp so I am definitely
concerned and intrigued by this whole
thing
yeah it'll be to see how it plays out
because I think there's a ceiling there
for Lamar Jackson that is every bit as
good as he was in college the question
is can he get there and and sometimes
you just can't but this is gonna be the
year where we're gonna see significant
improvement from him or it's gonna be
more of what we saw last year and it
becomes too predictable it becomes too
easy to defend we saw what happened with
the Chargers the second time through
it's like the second time through the
lineup with a pitcher you know what's
coming and it's easier to defend it and
there's gonna be a lot of teams out
there if they don't change things up and
continue to innovate and continue to
develop Lamar Jackson they're gonna have
a hard time moving the ball no question
it's just it's too hard to play that
one-dimensional style of football in the
NFL and like you said with teams being a
little studying a little more you know
and the proof was in the pudding I mean
the NFL defensive players they're just
too smart and too good to be fooled by
some of the same tricks week in and week
out with the read-option and some of the
run games and we saw Melvin Ingram and
Joey Bosa and company they were all over
some of the stuff because why yeah they
saw it the first time around oh I know
what that is oh I saw I remember seeing
his action with that and oh the guard
blocked down that's this runs coming so
yeah you becoming better at reading
those type of plays all together as a
defense and they're certainly gonna
we need to be more versatile and
especially more consistent in the past
game in 2019 all that talk about the
Browns taking over the division the
Steelers and their dysfunction the
Ravens kind of an afterthought even
though they are the defending Division
champion and whether they can repeat is
going to depend largely on what Lamar
Jackson can do in year two that's it for
us today another pft live tomorrow
another PFT ot Chris great stuff as
always everybody enjoy your day
check us out all day Pro Football Talk
comm when's the next unbuttoned we're
going today it'll be out this afternoon
gonna tape a unbuttoned dumore
quarterback rankings here around 12
o'clock it should be out by later this
afternoon Phil today Phil beyond two I
got to remind his you know big butt that
he's got to come on here he's you know
he's like a diva I got to give him a
daily schedule reminder but he should be
on today yes well give Phil our best
Chris and we'll see you tomorrow buddy
have a great day
[Music]
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports